wolfgang bosbach und sigmar gabriel
unser klartext herr gabriel wenn sie
sehen wie die auswirkungen waren in den
beiden bundesländern
meine frage an sie was bedeutet das
jetzt für den bund glauben sie es wird
konsequenzen geben in der korona politik
bei der verfolgung der masken raffkes
und dem test und im pflaster was wird
muss jetzt im bund passieren wenn ich
von den wahlen hoffe ich dass die
politik hier in der lage ist die doch
ganz massiven handwerklichen probleme zu
überstehen und zu beseitigen war es ja
nicht nur um wahlen geht es dann vor
allem um die gesundheit der bevölkerung
aber das wird auswirkungen haben na klar
in der union wird eine debatte über die
frage wie gehen wir jetzt mit diesen
spielern ergebnissen um an das kommt
sehr darauf an dass die partei zusammen
mit der csu klarheit schafft aber auch
gemeinsamkeiten schafft denn sonst wenn
das jetzt wochenlang eine debatte
darüber gibt wer da wohl schuld gehabt
hat und ja welchen anteil an den
schlechten ergebnissen hat dann ist
sozusagen der marsch unterhalb von 30
für die union auch bundesweit möglich
und so sehr darauf ankommen wie die
selbst mit dem ergebnis umgehen
herr bosbach rutscht die cdu jetzt in
einem desaster ihr kollege norbert
röttgen hat schon gesagt wir müssen
aufpassen
über die frage dass am ende ist da kann
ich mir darum geht ob wir regieren
können ähnliches wurde auch in
hintergründen gesagt also die gefahr
dass sie in den umfragen für den bund
dann immer weiter nach unten rauschen
das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab
welche konsequenzen die union zieht das
hängt sehr sehr eng mit dem thema corona
pandemie und ihre bewältigung zusammen
das was norbert röttgen jetzt sagt das
habe ich schon vor monaten gesagt buch
steht eigentlich geschrieben schönen
gruß an alle diejenigen die bei uns von
schwarz-grün träumen dass es schwarz
grün gibt wenn es für grün rot rot
reicht ich hoffe nicht dass man bei uns
ernsthaft glaubt dass dann die grünen
sich ihre für die union entscheiden
würden als für fdp und linkspartei
zwei dinge sind ganz ganz wichtig
erstens es muss aufhören dass jede ebene
sagt wenn es probleme gibt momente doch
nicht der bund zeigt auf die länder die
länder auf die kommunen die kommunen
zeigen auf bund und länder das
interessiert das publikum nicht die
menschen sehen die probleme sie sehen
wie wir sehr sehr langsameren vergleich
mit anderen ländern mit dem immer
streiten
und sie wollen jetzt rasch
entscheidungen wenn es beim wald bei dem
thema schnelltest und selbsttests mehr
vertrauen denn aldi und lidl gibt es in
bund und land dann haben wir ein problem
und ich darf darum bitten auch beim
thema impfen nicht jede kritik auch
sachlich begründete kritik sofort als
unbotmäßigen angriff auf die kanzlerin
und den bundesgesundheitsminister zu
betrachten
ich würde der bürgerbus bar wird sich
freuen wenn die regierung da etwas
kritischer auch selbstkritischer wäre
und sich fragen würden so lage bekannt
wie kommen wir jetzt in die erfolgsspur
zurück und zwar genauso wie sigmar
gabriel gesagt nicht in erster linie um
die parteien würden sondern um den
menschen bilden sie sagen sie würden
sich darüber freuen viele viele andere
menschen deutschland wird sich auch
darüber freuen wenn jemand in der
regierung verantwortung übernehmen würde
sich selbstkritisch einer fehler
eingestehen können sich aber glauben sie
wirklich dass wir demnächst von jens
spannend festival angehören werden dass
fehler passiert sind also vielleicht war
das tatsächlich heute abend ein weckruf
ich möchte mal ein kleines beispiel
nehmen was mich wirklich wundert immer
wenn es kritik gibt jetzt sind wir
wieder beim thema impfen heißt es sofort
also jetzt sollten wir uns erstmal
darüber freund also es schon so schnell
forschungserfolge gegeben hat und dass
es einen impfstoff gibt darüber kann man
sie aber nur dann freuen wenn der
impfstoff auf verimpft wird den haben
wir ja nicht angeschafft um ihn
auszustellen und bewundern zu lassen
sondern um menschen zu schützen stellt
es vor folgendes vor bei ihnen sind
einbrecher dann rufen sie die polizei an
110 würden sie bitte ganz schnell kommen
die sind so erstmal froh dass wir neue
streit
den wagen angeschafft haben wir können
jetzt nicht auch noch schnell zu ihnen
kommen so geht das nicht
herr gabriel so geht das nicht haben sie
das gefühl dass in diesem chor o na ja
die regierung viel zu oft die schuld von
sich gewiesen hat und dementsprechend
wähler jetzt auch reagiert haben gesagt
haben den fehler nicht eingesehen werden
dann müssen wir dann noch deutlicher
machen bibi fühlen also ich glaube dass
eine ganz großen fehler gewesen ist dass
bund und länder sich immer weiter
auseinander entwickelt haben dass die
ein scheinbar unterschiedliches
rollenverständnis haben die deutsche
kanzlerin angela merkel hat wie ich in
eindruck habe immer sehr rechtzeitig
davor gewarnt zu schnell zu öffnen und
es gab in allen parteien
ministerpräsidenten die sich am liebsten
überboten haben mit dem ergebnis dass
wir eine stop and go politik machen das
ist für die wirtschaft schlecht dass es
für die bürger die macht das verrückt
und die tatsache dass das auseinander
gelaufen ist und das am liebsten jeder
dem anderen immer erklärt hat was er
falsch macht kaum hat man abends eine
nachtsitzung hinter sich gebracht gegend
einer morgens morgenmagazin
und dann erklärt war eigentlich alles
nicht so gemeint wir müssen was ganz
anderes machen das geht so nicht und das
zweite ist schluss hat ist den handwerks
problem
ich mache man bei spielen als wir es
keine krise die vergleichbar ist aber
auch eine große krise als der mann zwar
hatten schleyer entführt wurde und die
raf sozusagen in deutschland den terror
organisierter dann gab es einen
krisenstab im kanzleramt
er hat bis zu fünf mal am tag getan
zwischen drei und fünf mal
der krisenstab letzte pandemie das
glaube ich einer woche
es muss einfach jemanden nach halten es
reicht nicht wenn man einen beschluss
fasst du musst dann hinterher auch
dranbleiben zugucken läuft das
eigentlich und ich glaube dass wir da
mal viel zu wenig auch auf flexibilität
zum beispiel auch mit blick auf das was
kommunen können eingesetzt haben die
wissen häufig viel eher wie man an die
menschen ran kommt in niedersachsen zum
beispiel wollte das land unbedingt die
über 80-jährigen selbst anschreiben
haben sie irgendwann festgestellt dass
sie keine mängel daten darüber haben
statt den kommunen das zu übergeben
haben sie die post gefragt und die hat
am ende die posse losgelassen dass sie
nach der eltern erfuhr namen gesucht hat
nach dem motto wenn der goldpreis bis
der eher dran als kevin und erst als das
öffentlich wurde und sich allein kopf
gefasst haben haben die im land das
richtige getan haben gesagt jetzt fangen
wir mal die städte und gemeinden durch
die daten also manchmal fragt man sich
wo ihr handwerk gelernt haben das ist
das was mich jedenfalls am meisten
ärgert sie sagen dass er jetzt die
meisten der gabriel gleichzeitig hat man
das gefühl deutschland wird das ja seit
wochen und monaten kritisiert immer
wieder was beim impfen passiert dass das
in den ländern nicht funktioniert dass
es beim test nicht funktioniert und es
ändert sich nichts
haben sie manchmal auch das gefühl
vielleicht können wir das in deutschland
gar nicht mehr haben wir es irgendwie
verlernt wir waren bei spitze in so
vielen dingen und jetzt hinken wir
überall hinterher jedenfalls können wir
krise nicht vielleicht ist einer der
grossen fehler gewesen dass wir nach der
flüchtlingskrise 25 10 216 uns nicht mal
genau angeschaut haben was muss ich
eigentlich im staatsaufbau tun wenn wir
erneut mit welcher krise immer
konfrontiert werden das haben andere
anders gemacht als die saas krise taiwan
erwischt hat
bitter dafür bezahlt jetzt bei cobit
hatten sie viel daraus gelernt ich
glaube es gibt eine ganz ganz geringe
zahl an infizierten und todesfällen in
diesem land ein hochentwickeltes land
wir schauen sowieso finde ich zu wenig
auf die südostasiatischen demokratien
vergleich das dass der fehler gewesen
dass wir zu selbstsicher sind dass wir
alles können aber selbst jetzt auch
nichts zurück zu blicken sondern man
kann nur hoffen dass jetzt
diejenige die der verantwortung tragen
sehen was sie politisch anrichten aber
auch welches maß an unsicherheit über
den umgang mit der pandemie inzwischen
in der bevölkerung herrscht
wahlergebnis heute ist für niemanden
eine überraschung auch wenn sie für
viele sehr bitter sind herr bosbach herr
gabriel können sie nochmal einsatz ihr
fazit zu dieser ersten wahl im
superwahljahr geben herr brust flechtet
erst dass das eine bittere enttäuschung
für die union und ich kann nur hoffen
dass dieses ergebnis nicht schöngeredet
wird oder dass es relativiert oder dass
es bagatellisiert wird sondern dass wir
wissen was die menschen von uns erwarten
erstens verloren gegangenes vertrauen
zurückgewinnen zweitens es muss
deutliche änderungen geben in der korona
politik übrigens auch in der
kommunikation und es würde der regierung
nicht schaden wenn sie kritisch und
selbstkritisch reflektieren würde was
ist im moment nicht gut er hat nichts
mit schuldzuweisungen zu tun und daraus
die konsequenzen zu ziehen nur ein
kleines beispiel aus der praxis
unser impfarzt hier in der heimat dr
mayer führt einen verzweifelten kampf
gegen das landesgesundheitsministerium
weil er sehr wohl residual spritzen
benutzen möchte mit der du eine impfung
zusätzlich vornehmen kannst also statt
67 impfungen wir könnten sofort 15 15
mehr impfen hier im rheinisch bergischen
kreis vermutlich in ganz deutschland das
land verbietet ihm das mit der
begründung er hätte den dienstweg nicht
eingehalten darüber müsse erst
entschieden werden
dieser kampf dauert seit wochen da gibt
es viele kleine beispiele und wenn sich
das nicht ändert früher sagte die welt
bot deutsch wo los aber organisieren
können sie im moment sieht es überhaupt
nicht danach aus weil viele länder
weltweit uns vormachen wie es besser
geht gabriel vielleicht einsatz als
fazit zu dem wahlergebnis dass wir heute
in rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
gesehen haben nach positiv gewinnen dort
wo politikerinnen und politiker das
vertrauen ihrer bürgerinnen und bürger
haben wo sie zeigen dass sie mit krisen
umgehen können und wo sie präsent sind
da gewinnen die auf wahlen das sieht man
in baden württemberg das sieht man in
rheinland pfalz
dann kann sie beide sich heute die zeit
genommen haben um hiermit uns klartext
zu sprechen über diese ersten wahlen im
superwahljahr 2021 herzlichen dank und
einen schönen abend noch an sie beide
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaute ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren